hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner tag
mails
ich bin heute nicht allein in meiner
küche es hätte ich heute meine zwei
freundinnen die einem trick kennt ihr
vielleicht schon uns hier einmal die
bahnen von batterie und hier die liebe
yasmin und yaz images und die beiden
damen sind heute hier zum gemeinsamen
grillen und essen und spaß haben und
fordern und coach in unserer weiter
und wir werden jetzt drei unserer
rezepte vorstellen und zwar kümmert sich
die anhörung ich bemühe mich um die
vorspeise und bei mir für das geht
einfacher gurkensalat natürlich etwas
leichter halten nicht so schwer dass
durch ein super ein gutes rezept passt
und auch für meine fitness kanal und bei
denen ich werde den hauptspeicher machen
und zwar einen hut
das ganz gut kann ein indem ich auch
öfters asiatische hoch hinauf und von
mir gibt typischerweise des wassers
werden kommt zu machen unsere männer die
haben sie mich fragen aufgeschrieben
wir wissen noch nicht was drin steht
aber ziehst wir sollen jetzt als sich
fragen stellen ich hoffe es stehen und
für die sachen schaffen eltern mit ihr
mit der vorspeise und ja man dann wird
es etwas besser können genau
also wir machen jetzt zusammen anpacken
salat und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal was du zutaten dazu braucht als
erstes werden wir zweiter preis auch die
haben wir leider jetzt schon beschnitten
und sind also schon gewürfelt aber wenn
ich dass wir jetzt zwei kleine vertrags
es gibt auch große dafür auch einfach
eine große menge an die wand gruß möchte
dann gebrauchen
eine zitrone zu tun vieles auf damit sie
wahrscheinlich zurückhaltend man schon
fleißig habt ihr auch gleich gestellt
wir brauchen so fünf esslöffel airplus
sorten besten hunde sollten schutz
genommen sind aber gerüstet
dann folge eine zitrone die nähe auch
verwendet haben hat es gut gemacht von
den stones und das ist ein und
schnittlauch ich kann mich schlecht
sagen viel eigentlich ambitionen
abgepackt und dann brauchen wir noch so
20 blätter minze ist natürlich erschwert
roster kleiner sind und jetzt wieder für
seinen abschied vorbereitet den das
dressing und da ist jetzt einfach einen
esslöffel olivenöl partie ist und dann
die zitrone die erste kleine schnitte
hat
das salz pfeffer und ein bisschen zehn
jahre sicherlich gerne verwendet es
einen teelöffel cydia da muss man auch
mal was süßes ins ausland zeugen klingt
lecker dann aber das geht
nicht einige gern wissen würden die
stadt denn so eine partei also ich finde
es sehr schön es ist schön weich aber
sie hat ganz intensiven geschmack
jetzt bin ich gut in salat war sie aber
nicht als 100 ich habe immer gesagt
schon nach höchstens aber nicht
feststeht
johnston lieben lernen am anfang fand
ich sie ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig
aber jetzt allerdings durch dabei ist
auch wirklich super von dem jahren also
die hand
sag mal was ich tun kann wie ich die kms
meine gurken so durch und ich möchte
hier das eindrücken und dann mit voller
wucht
das scrollen neue liegen gar nicht
zulegen
ja ich bin wenn ich jetzt eröffnen will
ich das weil ich bin auch gar nicht mal
so eben da jetzt eigentlich bin ich
denke das liegt einfach fitness video
ist aber auch eine aus video minister
ergebnis gesunde ernährung und mache
viele vegetarische plan in zwei sehr
wichtige
ich bewege mich so sehr quasi auf der
selbstfindungsphase in richtung
diese tiere selber anders ganzen wir
vereinbaren
deswegen ist einfach ganz kurz
zum abendessen gibt es bei uns jetzt
eher so ein spontanes soßen essen
ich habe gerade die verschiedenen soßen
der deutschlandflagge abgedreht
aus dem garten beim grillen leber drin
wir können das nicht jedem
villard nehmen wir wollen holzkohle ich
habe
sie ist alles und boutique ist heute
kommt mein zweiter tag und zwar ist das
der die entscheiden
das make-up asiatisch mit offenen armen
aus weil ich trag das am nächsten
auf meinen haaren es hat ein bisschen
sorgen
schönen
sanften aber auch um jetzt haben wir die
banken eine kleine gewechselt jetzt
kommen eigentlich dazu und dann halt
noch bei dem einen esslöffel öl habe ich
noch zwei wasser dazugeben einfach am
besten noch so ziehen stehen an und
damit eure durchzieht und jetzt nicht
super schöne sommer sondern
dies können hier habt und ich muss sagen
der super und jetzt zeigst du uns
einfach wie wir die hauptspeise machen
und was gibt's denn es gibt eine ungute
eine städtebaulich und während anna sie
brauchen dazu kartoffeln sind jetzt
jäger so viereinhalb es laufen dann in
zwei esslöffel zucker wasser das sind
200 bis 250 gramm thema damit brauchen
dann einen halben teelöffel cherry man
kann aber auch reis mein leben ich
bevorzuge shelly kupferberg lassen nur
wenn extreme antrag in aller ruhe da
noch zweieinhalb esslöffel meister dann
zweieinhalb esslöffel nass ist
das ist so was ähnliches wie fisch
ein halt ohne bestimmte dann in ein zwei
chancen zwei oder einen halben teelöffel
julia etwas pfeffer und natürlich dessen
so 200 nicht krank wird sich so viel
weil wir so viel zu grell macht da viel
zu bieten
ok dann darfst du starten und du sagst
einfach mehr mit der irgendwie
assistiert normal bedient sind
typische regel kommt jetzt unter
schmeckt
man kann jetzt auch einfach nicht
hinnehmen wenn man jetzt zufällig findet
das münchen hat mehr als aber darf auch
ein bisschen mehr fett das heißt muss
einfach sehen diesen weiter natürlich
sehr weiß raich und sind so für die
leute die sich mit fleisch fitness
ernähren also nicht wieder mit dem arsch
sind ist natürlich dass das 90 münchen
und video genau ich hatte mich gefragt
weil viele frauen in meinem sport
einfach denken sie müsse jetzt auch so
proteinriegel oder protein pulver nehmen
und gibt einfach nicht damit
auseinandergesetzt ob man bis jetzt als
durchschnittsfrau seite zwar die jetzt
nicht unbedingt ins bodybuilding müll
sondern auch schön aussehen will ob man
das wirklich braucht
also ich würde sagen ich hab dann
eskaliert weiter
superstars machen und wir richten hier
schon mal etwas unternehmen dazwischen
zeit ist mir natürlich und werden unser
falten pohl fertig machen da hatte ich
schon mal das video online gestellt
und wenn dann auch zu sehr zu bereiten
das auch schön durchziehen kann
hey willkommen heute wenn wir ein
bisschen experimentieren zwar
mittlerweile liebe persönlich verwendet
immer zum kochen und wollte daraufhin
backen
heute werde ich euch zeigen wie mit aus
dieser großen titeln leckeren snacks
wir haben jetzt unseren holz grüne
kälter wird vorbereitet man könnte ich
auch einen gasgrill machen aber kohl ist
einfach geil
viel spaß beim nachmachen daumen hoch
und abonnieren gefallen hat
wir haben jetzt hier das ist vorbereitet
und zwar machen wie oreo skis cakes im
glas und ich hab das einfach so
schraubgläser genommen weil ich keine
anderen schönen gläser so weckt liefert
ein ganz schön aber irgendwie doch ganz
cool ausbaustufen traditionskurs sie
dann ab fühlt weil dann kommt doch keine
fischerei und da manchmal sitzt drin
wären jetzt 66
weil wir heute sechs personen sind drei
und jetzt eigentlich einfach mal die
zutaten und zwar habe ich hier 16 euro
gags sind die ganz normal die normale
größe also keinen kleinen hier habe ich
acht after eight schreiben vielleicht
nehmen wir auch ein paar mehr immer
einfach spontan für die creme habe ich
hier bin von der gras capone 250 und 400
gramm sahne die haben schon schweiz
beschreibung mit bisschen salat oder
einfach ein bisschen sahne fest könne da
benutzen müsste aber auch gar nichts
also es geht auch ein kopfhörer sammeln
und hier einfach ein paar früchte also
rom bern und heidelbeeren die mädels ihr
dürft jetzt die apotheke ich geb dir
euch mal einfach dazugehören
ich gebe die hälfte und ihr dürft jetzt
einfach zerbröseln in die gläser reihen
und einfach die auf den scheiben mit
dazu einfach ein größenordnung keine
oben machen
ich werde da muss weg stellen und do
kann jetzt schon an einer großen
schüssel die mascarpone den teig
verrühren
das geht es einfach alles ohne handgerät
macht einfach alles natürlich auch in
gefrierbeutel geben und drücken mir mut
wir wollten die profis ganz klein
zerbröselt und mit zwei esslöffel
geschmolzener butter und hätte dann auch
schlacht getötet als ein richtiger
schnee fällt einfach mal zwei ist
sophie arbeite aber auch deswegen
gekommen ausgleich gut beigebracht
ich habe die sds sahne oder hast dein
freund die partie auch ein bisschen
beigebracht oder von einem jahr
was glaubst du wird der weg mal hingehen
ich meine schon viel bbl und chemie und
und viel und youtube was glaubst du
die creme abschmecken
das thema zitrone
ich finde es richtig nicht so genau und
die säure kommt ja super dann finde ich
das einfach mal im spitzel mit einem
loch ich glaub ich auch bei der
bestimmte menge bleiben und dann könnt
ihr jetzt einfach diese partie noch mit
ganz großer man könnte diese creme
einfach in die käserei schichten und ihr
dürft und einfach ein paar bildchen drin
verteilen moreau verletzung hat also
einen trinkt einen frühschichten
unterkriegen
mit einem spritzbeutel klappt das
natürlich super nicht dreckig könnte
natürlich jetzt auch im raum tischen
liegen
das genauso
wir haben
ein bisschen licht auf die janze aber
eben auch so zitronen
ja
daran gibt einfach nicht fertig stellen
den kühlschrank dazu also mindestens
zwei stunden zu fühlen
das ist auch optimal und dann darfst du
nimmst ein hauptgericht fertigungen
bereit
denn kochte schon vor 1 woche